la course est belle et bien lancée les
élections régionales auront lieu les 13
et 20 juin prochains pour ce nouveau
mandat à la présidence d'île de france
valérie pécresse devrait être candidate
à sa propre succession à la tête de
l'entente entre la liste soyons libres
et le parti républicain elle avait fait
basculer la région à droite lors du
précédent scrutin en 2015 face à elle
nous retrouverons audrey pulvar l'ancien
journaliste a officialisé sa candidature
le 26 janvier dernier
soutenu par anne hidalgo maire de paris
elle souhaite représenter une gauche
unifiée on écoute je suis portée par
toutes ces forces là eh oui oui c'est
ces jeux ne pouvait pas envisager d'être
la candidate d'un parti quel qu'il soit
je voulais d'abord je n'appartiens à
aucun parti je suis moi même une
candidate de la société civile et
ensuite je voulais vraiment porter une
démarche d'union d'union de la gauche
pour conquérir la région
ce ne sera pas jean michel blanquer air
dans le rôle principal pour la liste la
république en marche
l'actuel ministre de l'éducation
nationale s'est retiré pour laisser
place au député du val-de-marne laurent
saint martin mais jean noël barrot
député modem yvelinois supposés alliés
du parti lrm a annoncé qu'il souhaitait
briguer la place un imbroglio pas encore
clarifiée alors que pour bruno myle yens
également député modem yvelinois la
présidence régionale doit avant tout
servir à la cohabitation des parties
possibilité de pouvoir travailler avec
tout le monde et le proposé à
l'opposition aux oppositions de
travailler où on voit mais c'est un
échec ce quasi humain je voudrais dire
si ces mêmes pages et je vais employer
le terme de politique politicienne et ce
clanisme existe une espèce de bonis
régional exige autre liste celle
d'europe écologie les verts
rassemblant les divers partis
environnementaux avec comme figure de
proue julien bayou ils ont récemment
obtenu le soutien de benoît hamon à
travers son propre parti génération
l'ancien député des yvelines devient la
seconde figure de la liste dans le
département
enfin clémentine autain a été désigné
chef de file de la france
insoumise en tandem avec paul vannier la
liste a obtenu le soutien du parti
communiste français le 30 janvier
dernier pour former une fédération
populaire demandé
par jean-luc mélenchon depuis les
élections européennes en 2019
ces cinq listes ne sont pas définitifs
d'autres pourraient s'y ajouter tels que
le rassemblement national notamment une
élection régionale qui pourrait
également relancer les débats autour du
système électoral puisque selon un
sondage ifop
seulement un français sur dix aurait
l'intention de déposer son bulletin dans
l'urne le 13 juin prochain